hello and a very warm welcome to the
ftth council event here in munich i'm
talking to robin merch who is the ceo of
the broadband forum
robin you're here for the first time so
why now
well that's a good question we've been
we've been wanting to come here for a
few years this is a very interesting
event and uh
the more work we've been doing in the
fiber area the more i've wanted to be
here so
at last the timing has worked so it's
great to be here and i guess part of the
timing as well is of course you
announced your gpon certification late
last year yes absolutely so the timing
couldn't be uh couldn't be better we we
just announced it
um we're just starting to well we just
announced um the first certified
products um so we're now in the process
of of um
recruiting more vendors so it's a great
time to come here and talk about that
and see who else we can get involved and
i think you've also had a news
announcement of your own today yeah
absolutely we announced uh some q3 2011
uh broadband statistics um so one of
them uh well both of them are very
interesting to this part of the the
industry uh there's a 69 increase in
fgtx
subscribers um over the last year from
q3 2010
and a 30 increase in fiber to the home
um so both um very good numbers um so
the growth in fiber deployments is is
very good
how does what the broadband forum do
compare to ftth council how do you how
do you fit in together in the industry
yeah that's a great question there's
there's a good synergy between the
organizations you know i always i see
the fiber to the home council is very
much an organization which is
um you know supportive obviously of that
part of the fiber industry um but
they're they're they're more on the
advocacy and the kind of the marketing
side i think i i i don't mean to any
kind of uh
casting any aspersions but we're kind of
more on the technical side um so a lot
of the work that we do i think
complements what they do because we are
we do things like certification programs
we
do um we design architecture for fiber
deployments
we work on things like
remote management in a digital home
which again supports fibre deployments
um so so probably a lot more technically
led
but not to say that we aren't very
interested in um supporting
in marketing terms uh deployments of
broadband networks so i think there's a
very good synergy between the
organizations um so again i'll say we're
very pleased to be here and
and do that and support them yes i know
you have a booth here i think you're
speaking later at the conference what
are your impressions so far no i'm very
i'm very impressed it's um it's a very
very slick organization uh i mean i'd
always always sing that in the
uh on their website but actually being
here in person
really does sort of show you just how
well organized they are and i can see
why they've been successful well great
to see you and enjoy the event thank you
ftth connects the world
when are you getting connected ladies
and gentlemen
welcome to munich for the ninth edition
of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future
you